president biden's newest move to counter
russian aggression is a ban on importing
oil and natural gas from russia members
of congress from both parties support
the move even though it will push up
record high gas prices here in the u.s
this morning the average price per
gallon is 4.25
59 cents higher than it was last week as
wieser jang reports the president says
it was a necessary move
today i'm announcing the united states
is targeting the main artery of russia's
economy president biden ordered a u.s
ban on russian coal oil and gas which
makes up over 40 percent of russia's
revenue that means russian oil will no
longer be acceptable at u.s ports and
the american people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine but it also impacts gas
prices here at home
at a time when drivers across the
country are already paying record high
prices at the pump well over four
dollars a gallon it's it's more
expensive than i've ever paid actually
it blows my mind it's a crazy number
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
tweeted that he was thankful for the u.s
and president biden top american
companies are also hitting russia's
economy coca-cola pepsico mcdonald's and
starbucks and yum the parent company of
kfc and taco bell have all suspended
operations i think putin is determined
to dominate and control ukraine still
the director of the c.i.a testified that
putin appears undeterred by the
consequences and the military setbacks
warning the situation will only get
worse
where that leads i think is is for an
ugly next few weeks
in which he doubles down as i said
before with scant regard for civilian
casualties in which urban fighting can
get even uglier
there is also growing concern over the
americans who are still being held in
russia the whereabouts of wnba star
brittany griner are still unknown after
she was arrested on drug charges you can
see here state tv just released her
booking photo and yesterday president
biden called the family of marine
veteran trevor reed to reaffirm the us's
commitment to bring him home
reed was detained back in 2019 after a
night out dana
luija zhang thank you